previously on model lifestyle
I have finally started to book some jobs
from the castings we had and now I'm on
the way to my first photo shoot in China
so we got about 200 floors today and
this is what we have to do the whole day
just you John eNOS the ten minutes
before the train leave and we just
arrived Hey
and there are just so many people there
is 1.4 billion people in China
finally I'm home
hey if you are new on my channel
subscribe and hit the bell so that you
won't miss anything
[Music]
you
[Music]
the Sun brought on the next day and with
it another job many OTO gay gay gay need
of a hot spot ah we've been driving for
over 30 minutes and only then we realize
that I have forgotten my passport at
home the driver needs my passport to go
and book a train ticket with it at the
train station for my job on the
following day so he drove all the way
back to get it and it made me late for
the job today
the client was not happy so I did my
part and sincerely apologized then I
started the job free shot
you have to be shocked and
[Music]
okay
[Music]
this is the hairstyle they're going for
today
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in this photoshoot the client wanted
natural flowing movement and that is
what I gave him
[Music]
the time flew by as quick as an arrow
and before I knew it I was heading to
the airport to do another job
the next day came quickly and I was at
my new job working with one of the most
famous photographers in China I have to
confess one thing to you I am a coffee
addict
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the job is done and I rushed to meet up
with another team to travel all the way
to another city for a campaign photo
shoot
[Music]
and when I woke up my thoughts wandered
back to the time when I left home to
come to China
[Music]
hey babes
hey hey Starbuck c.j finito
on your way ready to go leaving on a jet
plane leave Oh a DC knows he'll be back
in three months again
[Music]
[Music]
but sometimes you got to do what you got
to do
I remembered saying goodbye to our dog
Togo but why don't go okay away right
there go
[Music]
and I remember our last coffee we had
together at the airport and I remember
saying goodbye to my wife for the last
time I love you only a few people in
this world can really understand what we
are going through emotionally at this
time
[Music]
I started to feel really sad and I
missed home so I forced my thoughts to
focus on the present time
[Music]
beautiful place it's okay
[Music]
another job in China is done and I am
all the way back to Guangzhou I got only
four hours of sleep and off I went to
the next job by now I started to feel
really tired but I decided to push
myself and still give my best to the
client
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and another job is done and dusted and
I'm exhausted and I cannot wait to get
home and sleep but the driver gives me
unexpected news I think Oh Kayla okay
lucky pass tonight we're going to
casting now could you finish the job it
is almost 5 o'clock
now I'm going casting work don't go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you nice to see you again yes
let's go home finally I can go home and
rest and I need it because it looks like
I have designer bags under my eyes
[Music]
I slept a good eight hours woke up and
straight to the next job
welcome to the photo shoot
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there's a new problem today
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the job went well and the client is
super happy before I knew it night came
and I was on my way to the airport to do
another job
[Music]
working everyday started to really hit
me hard and I knew I was getting burned
out but I needed money maybe I will tell
you why later
[Music]
you see the model life is a very busy
life and you got to travel a lot now it
is
midnight just after midnight and
tomorrow morning I have to wake up very
early and do a photo shoot and when I'm
done I take the next flight back home
sometimes it feels like it never stops
it's not a glamorous life as you would
think
you get tired and they there comes a
point where you don't want to stay in
hotels anymore you just want to be home
[Music]